Saudi Arabia has taken one tiny little
baby step towards considering women
normal humans like everybody else May
4th the King Salman of Saudi Arabia
issued a decree about women's rights in
his country the decree had two parts the
first part ordered government agencies
to list services that women can seek
from the government without permission
from a male guardian usually the father
or husband until now women could not
obtain government services without the
presence and permission of a male
guardian that's part one of the decree
part two of the decree directs
organizations to provide transportation
for female employees of course this is a
country Saudi Arabia where women are
brought by and large not allowed to
drive it's not clear yet which
government services will become
available to women now some in the
country believe that this decree means
women are no longer going to need a
Guardians consent to get a passport or
to work outside of their home to receive
medical care not totally clear the
decree might empower women to open
businesses on their own or maybe even to
travel outside the country by themselves
these are obviously not drastic
liberalisation but it's there's no doubt
that the decree on transportation for
women would actually have an immediate
impact on the lives of Saudi women as
well as businesses in Saudi Arabia where
it is still very difficult for women to
succeed in part because of barriers that
are placed by the Saudi system this
includes guardianship the prohibition
against driving groundbreaking in some
way I mean women are being allowed to go
slightly in the direction of being
treated as full humans and
self-actualized citizens in Saudi Arabia
it's slow it's not enough it's too
little too late but it is progress
should we be happy about that obviously
it is a step in the right direction it's
just hard to praise Saudi Arabia for
what they're doing now after all those
years of atrocities there's there's some
thought that this is all related to the
country being on the UN Human Rights
Council which is a total and utter
abortion a
very strict regime that rules the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia consistently
ranks among the worst of the worst in
Freedom House's annual survey of
political and civil rights they have
public beheadings in Saudi Arabia one of
approximately 30 countries in the world
that has corporal punishment this
includes amputations of hands and feet
for robbery it includes flogging for
lesser crimes such as quote sexual
deviance and drunkenness peaceful
dissidents are violently repressed
according to the Saudi Ministry of
Education women in Saudi Arabia attend
college at higher rates than men and
they cheerlead that is look at how
progressive we are women make up 70% of
those enrolled in universities for
social reasons however women make up 5%
of the workforce in Saudi Arabia the
lowest proportion in the world and I
barely even have to mention this Pat but
I'll mention it anyway systematically
anti-semitic right Jews attacked in
books news articles at mosques by Saudi
Arabian government officials by state
religious leaders often who are
promoting the idea that Jews are
conspiring to take over the world
as proof of their claims they publish
and frequently cite the protocols of the
Elders of Zion as factual sort of a
given though I don't think anybody's
going to be shocked by the anti-semitic
aspects of Saudi Arabia right that's
just sort of assumed yeah not a surprise
and honestly if there was a country that
we should be sanctioning when it comes
to trade and diplomatic relations yeah
it would be Saudi Arabia but we're not
going to do that because our economies
are too tied together and of course they
have a lot of oil
there's the others the oil part which is
the obvious part there's also a short of
sort of shared interest in stability in
any oil-producing region that's another
aspect and Saudi Arabia sort of serves
as a oil stability police officer of the
region or something like that by the way
not to go completely off-topic I might
have mentioned this recently on the show
the protocols of the Elders of Zion the
this long known anti-semitic
conspiratorial document one of the one
of the most vile things that's out there
in terms of the anti-semitic world
apparently it's very popular in Japan
not only in Saudi Arabia but the
protocols of the Elders of Zion which
Henry Ford actually uh would try to
spread very popular in Japan is I don't
know the status of Jews in Japan but I
guess it's not a place where Jews are
particularly common really and maybe
this connects to uh you know the
protocols being popular but that's
that's really disturbing is well yeah
not a surprise that Jews aren't
particularly common in Japan but the
fact that they would be mistreated that
is bizarre yeah and again it's not
necessarily physical mistreatment but
the idea that these anti-semitic
diatribes are spread around very weird
I'm very interested in going to Japan
you've never been right haven't been to
Japan so it also reminds me of
Confederate flags being quite popular
now in Brazil of all places
yeah and Confederate flags used to be
sold at very low rates to northerners
but now I think twenty percent of
average tour's clientele comes from the
north what uh what are people doing with
them in Brazil I have read I don't know
yeah I mean I don't know that they put
him on their pickup trucks like yeah in
the United States that's scary I didn't
know that all right send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show follow us there